points man has the odds for the first
snap to be taken by a quarterback for
the saints this year there's jameis
winston minus 250 he's the favorite
plus 200 taysom hill ian book plus 1600
trevor simeon trevor simeon plus 2 000.
i'd add another zero on the end of that
one frankly all due respect to trevor
simeon once the starter in denver though
after brock osweiler and peyton manning
2016 and then he's been a backup ever
since
i was surprised to see winston
as my favorite okay good i'm glad to
hear you say that well because tayson
hill was the guy last year this is how i
think sean payton threaded the needle
when drew brees got hurt in 2020
peyton said
that taysom played because he'd given
his word to taysom based on what
happened the year before when it was
teddy bridgewater who started five games
and won all of them when drew brees was
injured
but sean payton also said he had given
his word to jameis winston he'd be
allowed to compete for the job
2021 right even though he wasn't under
contract he ended up staying and it's
it's going to be an open competition and
we get to see what's happened to jameis
winston after a year
of watching drew brees learning from
drew brees learning from sean payton
this is a guy who threw for 5 000 yards
yes he had 30 interceptions 5 000 yards
though first overall pick in the draft
i guess when i think about it the
talent's there the potential there
i i guess i won't be shocked if he ends
up being the starter chris no i won't
either i mean we we discussed this a lot
last year when he was you know a free
agent and the saints first signed him
about his
his big time playability i mean what you
know his last year in tampa
hey there's still a lot of really good
we know there was the interceptions and
everything like that but look you know
you can look here these are some pretty
impressive like statistics i mean
they're those are like some baller type
things there now we know the negatives
and all those type of things but the
point is is that it's sean payton the
quarterback whisperer the greatest
offensive coordinator we've seen in the
history of football i mean in that
discussion you know what i mean a guy
that could really you know make a
quarterback grow and the guy's got big
time talent there's big time potential
there there really is i think that's
what we're saying like we could it could
be one of those crazy awesome stories
but i still would bet on taysom hill
being the starter week one i would
which story's better though that's the
thing i know right they're both good
with the opportunity
to to
advance his own legend what advances it
more taking this guy who was undrafted
that no one really thought could write a
quarterback in the nfl and turning him
into a high-end starter or reclaiming
jameis winston and making him a high-end
starter either one's a good story it's
just two different stories you're right
they're both awesome stories
i think he can win football games with
either guy there's no doubt about it
there'll be a little different formula
obviously but like one here i mean first
off
you and i over the last two years how
much have we talked about we know that
taysom hill is sean payton's favorite
pet project whatever toy
you know like you said he found this guy
he's into developing him he's got a
special skill set
he played pretty good last year it
wasn't great i know it wasn't perfect
but it was pretty damn good i mean what
was it three in one four and one i can't
remember exactly you know they had that
eagles
yeah where they were one i think i think
it was four and one right yeah the
eagles game where they they kind of blew
it in a lot of different ways it wasn't
taysom hill's fault they lost that
football game um i i just feel like with
the way they're built and everything
like that
and sean payton i don't know why i just
feel like he's got a itch to do
something different and taysom hill is
something different and going to be a a
different look and threat for for
opposing defenses so if i had money i'd
bet if i had your money i'd bet on him
here's one here's what
wait why would you bet your own money
yeah i'd rather have
what
i'd rather have your money and then take
it when i win
hey uh um
yeah oh so so it's my loss but you get
exactly the winnings i just get my money
back
i'm the bank that covers your losses and
gives you the winnings i get it yes i
think one of the factors
for
sean payton will be which of the guys
is more flexible and adaptable
when peyton shows up sunday morning game
day with five new plays that he thought
of that night right yeah and and which
of these guys can run those plays
and pick them up quickly because we know
that's what sean payton does he's always
on the lookout yeah for new ideas
and and uh i think that's a factor
if if you can process adapt and run that
play with like a walk through
you know in the hallway outside the the
buffet room at the hotel yeah then then
you you're gonna you're gonna be the guy
that that wins his trust it's a great
point it's a a phenomenal point and it
it's a point that holds more water with
a guy like sean payton as compared to
maybe the rest of the play callers in
football because yeah it is a lot
there's a lot of verbiage and that's why
drew brees was awesome oh sean hey you
know sean could come into drew brees on
a saturday morning and be like you know
i noticed something on film yesterday
when i motioned to this they play cover
three all the time so i drew up nine
different plays for cover three we're
going to run them real quick in the
walk-through today no big deal and drew
of course is the computer and it's like
okay i got it straight sure coach all
right how do i read it
okay good and then he goes out and
dissects you and you're right though
there's real value to that there's no
doubt
yeah and uh we won't know that until it
happens and maybe peyton won't know it
until it happens
there may be a certain amount of
experimentation that's what makes the
preseason important this year last year
obviously we didn't have one this year
three games i bet he gives
jameis one as a starter taste someone as
a starter just to see i agree to see how
they prepare right see you know he'll
test him he'll throw some of those curve
balls at them he'll have some new plays
that he jams into the game plan the the
day of the game and he'll see how they
react i mean i assume that's what he'll
do based upon the way he's done things
in the past you have to see who's going
to be adaptable to those changes that
can come
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports